hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm monster on a robe
again and today we're gonna be talking
about the new behemoth trailer that
recently just released today and
basically its showcase some of the
gameplay from it a few other things like
the armor the weapons and a bunch of
other things so let's get straight into
this little breakdown so first up the
official trailer for the Final Fantasy
14 collab with monster hunter world is
going to be an August 2nd in Japan and
August 1st for the people in the West
and America because of time zones this
obviously will have behemoth when it
releases and a quick breakdown of the
trailer shows is going to be new armor
and a new weapon no clue if that's the
only weapon or if there are going to be
more throughout the game with its
sealing when they showed but regardless
the armor looks really cool and on top
of that there seems to be some type of
new animation for transporting with when
within the gathering hump which is also
really nice also gameplay of behemoth
was shown in quick bursts but the fight
looks pretty tough with him having an
alternate phase when his body is red
which might cause the meteor shower you
see later in the trailer and as well it
looks like a possible event quest more
COO it gets a little bit bigger and
instead of an egg Kulu carries its
crystal from the Final Fantasy series
and this could also just be speculation
but it looks like the CAC Tour might be
replacing the Grimalkin but I'm not
entirely sure but there seems to be a
plethora of them around the map
regardless and on top of that moogle
seems to be in the game as well which is
this little cat thing at least a little
flying cat thing with a type of horn so
that might be an armor for your palico
and they also showed the new Pookie
outfit towards the end which looks he
looks like a little baby behemoth which
is super cute and I cannot wait to make
a guide up once this monster releases
let me know if you guys are hyped about
this just based off the trailer what
guys what do you guys think is going to
be your favorite thing the Pookie outfit
the palico outfit the armor the weapons
anything like that or just the fight in
general love to know your thoughts but
what that guys like the view enjoy
subscribe before I cover the solo guides
for most of the monsters in monster on a
roll then I do plan on making a God for
behemoth once he releases on August
first and on top of that I cover tips
and tricks and the event quest every
week to let everyone know which quest to
do which ones are new and what the
rewards are for those super guys like
that consider subscribing and with that
guys my two most recent videos will be
on screen if you guys wanna check that
out bye guys hope you have a great
yesterday and peace out I hope you
enjoyed the video